I am the moderator my name is Chris
Donohue my grandchildren are ninth
generation pittsburghers so this thing
means a lot to me what is the role of a
moderator we've heard from our Irish
ambassador and I could only think that
the proper role of the moderator reminds
me of the role of a cadaver at an Irish
wake and what is the connection between
the moderator and the cadaver at an
Irish wake the answer is unfortunately
the cadaver is necessary for the
function but no one expects to hear much
from them that will be my role today and
in fact from our distinguished list of
panelists we will expect poetry there is
much depth behind what they know we'll
have poetry on sources of growth and
innovation in our company federated
investors the founding fathers had this
little rule of thumb namely that yes you
can paint any picture you want you just
have to stay on the canvas this is a way
of saying that is the strength of
innovation comes from individuals
perhaps it is even the triumph of the
individual or the beauty of human
capital these are things that would help
us I think avoid Malthus disease or even
worse Irish fatalism so what we intend
to do in this panel is do the light
thing if you want the heat thing head on
downtown with your posters that's not
what we're about we have serious
professionals with serious commentary
and I feel like I did when my one
daughter we would play wiffle ball
during the summer and I was a lawyer
then had two big bags because we were
working on a really big deal and she
would say it's time to play wiffleball
she was a pretty good hitter decent
speed feeling pretty good like to play
every night first night I come us and no
I have too much stuff to read the second
night I came home with the same poor
excuse and so this little first grader
said to me why don't you just have them
move you into a slower reading group
and that is how I feel with this
distinguished panel well we're going to
learn about how data you may even learn
about how big gazeta bites are will
learn about how the strength of national
diversity can be used as an advantage
will learn about how new Europe can play
ball will learn about software and its
many advances and how it in fact it
advances a lot like children sometimes
growing up but not quite maturing but to
begin our panel I'd like to introduce
first our professor of economics and
social science at the temper school
Steve Klepper and he is going to talk
about human capital Steve thank you so I
want to talk a little bit about
accumulating research which I've played
a part in and my co-author Sergei
braginsky has as well that digs into the
question about where the new firms come
from particularly great new firms that
help build an economy and one part of
this research that I've particularly
focused on is where two great new firms
come from in tremendous industry
clusters exemplified today by Silicon
Valley but in a much earlier era by
detroit and the automobile industry so
this is a question obviously of utmost
importance both the United States and
globally how do you grow these great
modern firms and I think one of the
surprising things that's come out of the
research and economics is to find that
about twenty percent or so of all the
entrance into new industries are
actually founded by people who worked in
firms in the same industries and most
importantly these turn out to be the
best performers the best and the
brightest are started by people that
were already in the industry setting up
competing firms and this is particularly
true from the best and the brightest
that comes from yet the best performing
firms and this is nowhere more true
historically than silicon valley this is
perhaps
the most extraordinary engine of
economic growth not just in modern times
but perhaps ever this tiny region which
accounts for less than 1% of the
landmass of California let alone the
United States it counts for over twenty
percent of all venture capital
investments in the United States over
roughly thirty percent of all newly
issued companies on the stock market and
yet it's tiny so how could a region like
this grow so enormously back in the
1950s almost being a cow pasture well
the region got its name from silicon the
main ingredient in semiconductors and
nobody disputes the fact that it's the
semiconductor industry that really got
Silicon Valley going but what's
remarkable is initially Silicon Valley
had no presence in the semiconductor
industry and one firm now not even that
well known but certainly well known in
its time fairchild semiconductor got the
whole industry going so many people have
left Fairchild and it's descendants that
there's these spin-offs have been dubbed
very cleverly the fair children and to
name yet a few of these famous firms
today Intel AMD national all over their
heritage to Fairchild over a hundred
firms entered in the semiconductor
industry in Silicon Valley but here's
the remarkable part of the story when we
take a look at these firms and what led
to the impetus of people leaving and
starting their own firms over and over
again what we see is discord they left
particularly Fairchild and later its
descendants over disagreements about
strategy management marketing a whole
range of things and the key to the
success of Silicon Valley is the ability
of people to leave and form their own
competing firms in the same industry
many people think Silicon Valley is soua
generous that it's peculiar an
idiosyncratic to
qualities of the semiconductor industry
the pioneering spirit of California and
its restrictions on preventing firms
from stopping employees to leave their
own firms but the accumulating research
suggests it's a complete opposite
Silicon Valley is age-old the same thing
happened in Detroit in the early part of
the 20th century in the early in the
automobile industry the great firm for
at least once great firms Ford Chevrolet
in general motors that precursor to
Chrysler all emerged from the same
impetus people disagreeing with their
employers and being able to go off and
start their own firms this isn't just
the u.s. phenomenon and Sergei will talk
a little bit more about this it's true
of many places today the Israeli
information and communication technology
industry which has been an enormous
success the Australian and New Zealand
wine industries and even countries like
Bangladesh and it's growing cotton
garment industry so what's the lesson
about this both to the United States and
globally well the lesson is it's
incredibly easy to suppress this kind of
activity and indeed established firms
always want to suppress this or nearly
always and try aggressively to do it we
see a recent inadvertent change in the
law in Michigan that strengthened the
ability of employers to prevent
employees from leaving and competing
with them and early analyses suggests
that what's happening is it's
suppressing both employee mobility and
the formation of new firms something
Michigan can hardly afford at this
moment this is just one way that this
can be suppressed and there are much
deeper global lessons both for the
United States and the rest of the world
I'll turn that over to Sergei
I would like to indeed pick up where
your where you left over and take a more
global international perspective
basically about the same issues the
ideas and opportunities about which
stephen thought and chances to develop
these opportunities into new businesses
and in whole new industries are actually
very important even perhaps more
important than many other things that
have been described as being very
important in international development
like you often hear that a lot of
countries cannot reach the level of
development of the US and other advanced
nations because of poor institutions and
that some thats the kind of research
that i have been doing partly because my
own background I come from the former
Soviet Union where where I grew up in
their witness the collapse of the Soviet
Union the start of the transition to a
market economy with which many hopes
were associated but eventually so far it
hasn't played really well to what
everybody hoped 15 years ago it would
lead and the main culprit was supposed
to be poor institutions and to some
extent this is correct but when you
compare the situation in Russia at the
start of the transition with situation
situation in many other countries
including the same Bangladesh these
countries are all in in the state where
there are no good institutions the
nevertheless some countries do develop
and one of my research areas which is
related to Japan led me to look into how
Japan became the first-ever non-white
non-european or not not an out offspring
of a European nation country to
assimilate advanced Western technology
and became and become a major economic
power it turned out that it all started
everybody's familiar with the post-world
war two Japanese miracle but the first
and perhaps even more important Japanese
miracle took part in the late 19th
century
the country didn't have any modern
institutions indeed it didn't have any
even in corporate law nevertheless
corporations emerged one after another
with pretty good supervision of its
management by powerful shareholders who
did not rely on any kind of developed
financial markets to do that and I'm
talking about the first modern Asian
industry which was cotton spinning
industry in Japan it eventually became
one of the largest industry in the world
the second actually only after britain
all this happened based on not on some
kind of an institutional reform that
preceded it but precisely based on those
factors that Steven mentioned were
clearly important later on in Silicon
Valley and in other in other examples
that he mentioned it was the free
exchange of ideas the free exchange of
workers and most importantly it was
importing global ideas and then using
them to produce things that would be
exported globally as we all know many
Asian well the the East Asian miracle of
post-world war two year and not just
Japanese but other Asian titles is very
well known and one of the most
characteristic features once again is
importing a lot of great technologies
processing them by means of very very
elaborate interaction of firms within
those countries and then going back to
the global market with new products and
basically capturing those global markets
so all this tells us the same lesson
that the Silicon Valley and other
examples that Stephen gave tell us about
that the exchange of ideas the free flow
of ideas and not just abstract floating
in the air ideas as they're sometimes
represented economics but ideas embodied
in workers in pioneering entrepreneurs
is the key not just the growth of
industries within countries but to
international growth and in this regard
Lee the only other thing I want to
mention is the role of mobility workers
not just domestically but
internationally that did play a big role
according to my study and what happened
in Japan in the 19th century they base
sent their best and brightest to study
abroad then these people chose to came
to come back and created this industry
this happened with the Taiwanese
semiconductor industry as far as I know
again a lot of people who came to study
and work in the US then went back and
created startups back in Taiwan this
benefited not only the Salinas issues
often misunderstood on both sides there
is a talk of international workers
coming in this place in home country
engineers in the u.s. there is a talk of
brain drain from on the developing
country side and I think both these
Warriors are greatly greatly exaggerated
if not completely misplaced because the
there is little or no evidence that
American workers or American engineers
are being displaced by competition from
foreign from immigrants and there is
very little evidence of negative effects
of brain drain on on on the countries
which export talent to the United States
so in our joint paper we probably state
unequivocally that perhaps the
immigration policies should be tailored
to promoting this exchange of workers
internationally rather than putting
restrictions on them I understand that
there are national security concerns but
I grew up in the Soviet Union as I
mentioned the most regulated country in
the world and we all knew that bad guys
will always find ways around even the
strictest of regulations it's only the
good guys who are prevented from doing
good things by by these kind of things
so I think there are some favorable
trends under the current administration
of shortening the process in time for
for green card holders applicants I
think that h-1b caps are certainly a
very bad idea that maybe should be
abolished all together and the two-year
home home country residence requirement
which is another thing that is even
little mentioned in the current debate
where the United States basically offer
countries that want their people back
free way of doing
by preventing these people from staying
in the United States which affects a lot
of developing countries is also
something that I don't think benefits
other either the United States all the
countries that debt request is away from
the US government Thank You Stephen
Sergey Erica from your perch is a
professor of in in the Department of
Engineering and public policy you've
done a lot of research on how nations
can take these new ideas and work them
with their own their own aspects and
come up with diversity as a strength
would you put another flavor on what our
two opening professors went with sure
absolutely I'd be happy to um I I tend
to want to quote Paul Krugman the Nobel
Prize winner and in 1995 he criticized
economics for occurring in a wonderland
of no spatial dimensions and I believe
the same is true today of engineering
management our corporate management of
technology as well as nat nations
innovation policies both within their
nation and internationally so that's a
big statement for me to make and the
question is why do I believe that so I'm
an engineer by background and my
research shows that when you move
manufacturing overseas due to
differences not everyone focuses on
labor costs and the difference in labor
costs but you look at cultural
differences manufacturing operational
differences so we're talking differences
in yields in downtimes material quality
material cost those differences are so
significant as that when you model them
we find that they switch the most
competitive technology and for a matter
of fact most competitive technology in
the United States when you're looking at
this is the hot new emerging technology
but when you move manufacturing instead
overseas those economics switch and the
old technology becomes more economically
viable than the new technology and the
firms in both of the industries that
I've studied follow those economics so
rational right they move manufacturing
overseas they produced the old
technology overseas and they stop
pushing forward that new technology back
in the United States and so the question
then becomes we'll wait a second as
nations how should we be thinking about
this what should we be doing and I think
the first thing that I would say as we
think about this problem is that I don't
believe this necessarily needs to be the
case the problem here is that the
engineers back in the developed
countries in the United States are
manufacturing or creating these new
products with the US manufacturing
environment in mind and so it's not that
our hot new technologies to continue
Moore's law or a hot new technologies
for energy savings and automobiles it's
not that they have to not be more
economically viable when we move
manufacturing overseas it's that we have
to actually understand what that
manufacturing environment is overseas
and how to educate our engineers how to
get them overseas and understand a Tonya
factoring environment so that they do
produce new technologies that are more
competitive in those environments so
that's one the second thing is you might
want to say okay as nations should we
then be keeping manufacturing in
developed nations to encourage the hot
new technologies to continue to be
pushing forward and again here I think
you need to be careful you say no we
cannot take a one-size-fits-all approach
to technology instead one if a firm can
afford multiple manufacturing facilities
it should be using multiple
manufacturing facilities globally
whether that's a Chinese firm in United
States firm to diversify its
manufacturing portfolio on the other
hand if a firm cannot afford multiple
manufacturing facilities it's a small
high-tech firm it needs to understand
how where it manufactures is going to
change its most competitive design and
as nations we have to understand how
where we choose to manufacture is going
to change the direction of our
technologies the technologies that
develop and the technologies in our
society
Thank You Erica one of the other things
we're going to do here in a couple of
minutes is we're going to get to a few
questions dr. Skinner said we weren't
supposed to do that but we are taking
our own initiative to do that we're
going to allow each of our professor to
make a few comments before we get to
that but now turning to New Europe
marcin has written about how people
headquartered Poland and otherwise and
make a real difference growth through
innovation perhaps even compromising the
dollar is the lead currency in the world
but how do you see these ideas impacting
your work and the future of New York
thank you first of all thank you to the
organizers for for setting up this
amazing conference if I can say about
myself I'm an assistant professor of
economics at kozminski University in
Poland until recently I was advisor to
the Poland's deputy premier minister of
finance economies at the IMF for the
five for the last five years in
Washington DC when I left us went back
to Poland became the chief economies of
pko BP the largest bank in Poland and
recently along with my academic job I
also joined the World Bank as a senior
economies for sunshine Eastern Europe so
what I want to talk today about is
actually not only about new Europe but I
thought I could enlarge the topic and
talk about the emerging markets and talk
about what does the future hold for
these countries and whether the growth
economic growth post-crisis in these
countries will be lower or higher than
before before I go into details let me
just give you the two messages one I
think that growth economic growth
post-crisis will be lower for years to
come that we have experienced in the
last decade and second that innovation
will have an even more important role to
play in enhancing economic growth in the
future but let me start by repeating
what their sources of growth are as a
students of economics and others now
you can look at GDP from various aspects
but one of them is that you look at GDP
that is due to contribution of
investment contribution of labour and
thirdly contribution of productivity on
innovation human capital and if you look
at these three sources of growth in the
post-crisis weld my interpretation is
that the global economy will be now
glowing slower let me tell you why first
of all I think that in any years to come
global economy will be a particularly
emerging markets which we will be
investing much less than before and this
will be so because financial flows
globally will diminish mostly from
developed countries to developing
countries and the cause of financing
will also increase let me give you an
example before the crisis in 2007
pawleys enterprises can guarantee prices
check enterprises and others could
borrow money on international private
markets at 10 basis points of 15 20
basis points above what similar German
companies could borrow it that is one
tenth of a percentage point today the
same enterprises have to pay at least
two percentage points more for capital
than two years ago so all other things
eco enterprises in emerging markets will
be investing less in the near future and
probably also in the medium term future
second in terms of input of labor into
GDP growth here again I think that this
contribution to grow from labor will
also diminish there's a number of
reasons but let me just give you two one
is that they were there will be lower
migration flows and I do not need to
preach to you what the problem in the
USS with all the foreigners having
increasing problems with actually
entering the US and studying at such
prestigious universities as this one and
I think is a global phenomenon European
Union is also trying to erect all new
kinds of bear
years for immigrants to come in without
these immigrants labor contribution will
be going down particularly that and
there's a second point a lot of emerging
markets and others are actually on the
verge of an accelerating population
aging let me take an example of China
they've been very successful with
implementing their one-child policy
there is one family could only have one
child this been great for savings and
investment in the last twenty and thirty
years but very soon the same kids though
the other side of the coin will be that
the population in China will be aging
very quickly which will which will mean
a lot of lot of people will retire and
will no longer contribute to increasing
GDP and third of all and most
importantly for this session the third
source of growth is innovation and Here
I am slightly more optimistic than about
the other two factors and let me
numerate three arguments for why one
could be optimistic and three arguments
for why why one could be a bit more
pessimistic on being optimistic I think
the important part is that we have still
not we still don't know whether
information communication technologies
ICT have produced all the applications
that these general purpose technologies
can produce and as an example when the
steam engine was first developed as
everyone knows it was used to pump water
out of coal mines in Wells and Scotland
and only later people discovered that
the steam engine could be used for
everything almost everything else it's
similar with ICT we don't know what
other applications can be developed in
the future mostly in Silicon Valley I
guess that can rejuvenate productivity
growth worldwide and second importantly
ICT also helps immensely to diffuse
knowledge globally mean for now for
someone in Poland Bangladesh Africa
Paraguay you just need to go on Google
and write whatever you want and you will
get the some part of the knowledge that
you were seeking I mean I wish my
students were actually doing less of it
but they beg at the University but the
knowledge is right there and third human
capital globally is improving it's not
only that students for emerging markets
are coming to the US but locally
domestically universities are very
quickly improving and this will also
bring benefits in the future but on them
on the negative side productivity growth
cannot very often come without high
investment and then I said that if cause
of financing will increase there will be
lower investment and therefore lower
productivity growth I mean you have to
buy computers before you can get the
benefit of them if you don't have money
don't have access to financing or the
financing is costly you're not going to
buy computers second I think global
public budgets for years to come will be
significantly squeezed they will have to
pay off the debts that's going to been
accumulated during the crisis what will
it mean that some of the spending items
that are less politically sensitive like
innovation and human capital will be
compromised so again as a source of
productivity growth this will diminish
and third of our population aging I mean
the question is can you teach an old
whores in your tricks I don't know but
so far the research shows that with
population aging naturally the
productivity growth rate can decline
because most of innovations are produced
by people between the age of 30 and 45
if you look for instance that Nobel
Prize winners most of the research has
been done during that age so I don't
want to go into the second part of what
i wanted to say which is worthy to what
needs to be done to make sure that
growth is faster but let me just finish
with this and and just say that again in
my view growth and economic growth in
the new future globally will be slower
and innovation will have to play even a
bigger part than before thank you Marcin
shows us that the beauty of
economics professors goes overseas as
well on the one hand and on the other
and perhaps a bill bill shirtless as a
professor of computer science who's
talked a lot about software that is only
five percent of the economy yet it's
twenty-five percent of the growth and
forty percent of the productivity
perhaps this will tilt us towards the
optimistic bill thank you so this is a
meeting about economics and policy so
why talk about software software is a
kind of a secret ingredient in global
business and innovation it's not so much
of a secret from practitioners but it's
perhaps more of a secret from economists
and policymakers so software has had a
disproportionate impact on growth as
Chris just noted and as you know with
the productivity paradox there was this
question about the role of ICT in
productivity as you know that's
documented and and also have this
documentation regarding the relative
scale of the software sector in the EC
and the impact on growth and increased
productivity software is everywhere in a
modern fighter aircraft the percentage
of total systems function that is
enabled or manifest in software has
risen to eighty percent I've heard a
figure of forty percent quoted for
modern automobiles organizations the
role of software is shifted from
processed support within functional
silos two interconnecting systems within
enterprises and also across enterprises
ERP within enterprises SCM with the
supply chain crm with customers these
technologies are now so widely adopted
that the vendors consider the large firm
erp market to be saturated so now the
focus is not just on exploiting the
ability to rapidly enact global
processes within an enterprise but also
to analyze link and learn from the
massive amounts of data that are
collected so largely as a consequence i
t's desks have stepped back
from their traditional role in mediating
between users and the IT systems
enabling direct interaction which means
that far more individuals in an
organization and around the organization
are empowered to take direct action
often with far-reaching consequences and
also as a consequence these systems
support immediate electronic enactment
of decisions and consider for example
this current discussion about this
millisecond stock trading look ahead
window so all of these changes add up to
tremendous agility responsiveness and
flexibility enabled by software and ICT
in the global enterprises now deep
technology advances have enabled all
this it's more than just savvy CIOs and
good process it's actually those who
have the technical technological
advantage do better and they realize
more benefits both in terms of
functionality the kinds of things that
they can do with the systems and also
flexibility consider for example amazon
google and ebay these technological
advances have also enabled better
control of x versus build decisions and
the enrichment of the supply chain the
global supply chain for the IT systems
themselves and this is this outsourcing
phenomenon that we talk about so often
all of this sounds very good that
software is this kind of constantly
growing source of value but there's also
a dark side to this story which is that
the engineering of innovative software
has not yet matured into a rigorous
discipline in spite of the pervasiveness
of adoption of this building material of
software and in fact the risks and
difficulties are growing both in
severity and diversity we constantly
experience failures related to
reliability cyber security flexibility
software related problems have
contributed to life-threatening failures
and healthcare devices space missions
skating failures and telecom systems and
power utilities small typographic errors
have contributed to large decreases in
market cap for some firms because of the
impacts of those errors and additionally
we struggle just to build the software
in the first place and often too often
fail so we have this strange
juxtaposition of technological
sophistication which is growing rapidly
on the one hand and growing risk on the
other we kind of expect our engineering
disciplines to mature in the sense of
arriving at repeatable practice and this
is the story in so many other areas and
we expect that a kind of a natural path
to repeatable practice routinization and
commoditization and this brings me to
the point of my remark which is that
software is special not in the sense
that everyone is special but rather
because software uniquely has this
purely abstract and synthetic character
it lacks fundamental physical
constraints the constraints that
characterize traditional engineering
disciplines it's about manipulating
symbolically so the only real limit is
our ability to achieve intellectual
control so while we have commoditization
in software and ICT we also have this
endless growth and capability at at the
top end just as soon as we figure out
how to routinized something we evolve
new capability to better compete and and
this is enabled by continuous continuous
technological advancement and that in
turn is enabled by this unboundedness of
software so for example the size of the
Windows operating system in less than a
decade has grown by more than a factor
of 10 in terms of capability so another
way of saying it is we're not going to
get to a plateau instead we are
constantly disrupting ourselves and this
is what i mean by the endless value
spiral this constant disruption we have
a half a century of kant's of unceasing
revolution
in the ICT industry and in fact for the
last 40 years this is also the story of
the internet it's it's not a steady
continuous growth so what conclusions
can we draw first mere presence in the
market requires keeping pace with this
ongoing innovation second leadership in
the market requires an active role in
defining the architecture of new systems
and doing so as a first mover the
economics of software are focused on
externalities the third conclusion is
that the technical challenges for
software are broadening we have
challenges of Software Assurance of
large-scale architecture of handling
massive amounts of data of concurrency
and and the light forth the risk
management models that we develop for
business and also for our engineering
practices need to be continually
adjusted to accommodate to these new
realities of software and IT enabled
business practices and and finally the
role of software leadership in the
global economy is growing and this is
becoming increasingly recognized with
the result that the competition is more
intense at every level of capability and
this leadership is maintained through
constant innovate investment in
innovation and in people costly physical
facilities are not needed in the
software economy there's no concept of
manufacturing education and technical
currency are the fundamental and ongoing
challenges in fact dan rooney earlier
quoted Craig Barrett of intel on this
subject in software the capex is
education so the bottom line is that we
are growing in our dependence on
software it's a principal enabler of the
global enterprise we gain tremendous
power and agility from software
capability in diverse sectors to compete
we need to continually move forward in
this area thank you Bill you have all
this soft
are going it's going to create data
we're pleased to have with us also Randy
Bryant king of data also known as the
he's a professor at CMU and Dean of the
School of Computing but he's also able
to get from data to real stuff Randy
thank you so my essay I talked about the
mushrooming amounts of data and all the
computation that can be done with it a
prime example being Google and the fact
that they are made a multi-billion
dollar company this whole business model
is to collect data that's freely
available over the internet package it
in a way that you find useful and make
you look at ads and click on them to
gain revenue so it's a amazing industry
and really explosive growth but I
thought to sort of get back more to the
topics of today I would follow more on
what Bill service was talking about and
talk about the whole global IT industry
and the way I'll do it is to talk about
first about Infosys which is a company I
visited last January of course it's the
largest of the Indian software companies
and an economic miracle in itself in
1991 the Infosys was a two million
dollar company today it is a five
billion dollar company which is a growth
that's unprecedented it employs about a
hundred thousand people most of them in
India and it's an interesting look at
that that every year they hire about
15,000 new people and put them through a
training program and turn them into
software engineers in a matter of of 18
months I'll now compare that to the u.s.
a comparative company would be Microsoft
which has roughly the same number of
employees 93,000 million 93,000
employees although it's a 20 billion
dollar company
in the US as the dot-com boom hit its
peak the number of students in the u.s.
majoring in computer science also
reached its peak and as the dot-com boom
went into a bust the number of us
students plummeted to about a factor of
two off of the peak the and we saw that
actually in the number of applicants to
our computer science program here also
dropped by roughly a factor too although
we were looking for only 130 students
out of two thousand applicants so we
never really had a shortage the the
interesting thing was the tail of that
decline has been pretty long and hard in
the u.s. because of a sense that well
gee if Infosys and it's Indian
counterparts are rising so quickly and
they hear all these stories about the
number of IT jobs being outsourced that
must mean there's really no future in
that and a lot of very smart people and
parents we're telling their children
don't major in computer science there's
no future in that unless you're willing
to work for 40 rupees a day you should
do something like safe like be a banker
good I do but the reality is actually
right now today there are more IT jobs
in the US then there were even at the
top of the peak of the dot-com boom and
that's been the case for several years
in fact that even though the there's
been a explosive growth in this business
outside of the US the US has also
maintained a strong and steady growth
and continues to so one interesting
itself though is that the number of
students giving computer science degrees
in this country is about twenty two
thousand a year across all of the US
universities and that's not really
enough to sustain growth and in fact a
lot of companies are having to hire in
foreign countries now not
to decrease their labor costs but
actually because that's where the talent
pool is and so I think one of the
challenges for our country is again
since our students largely choose what
they major in and that making sure they
understand where the opportunities are
is an important thing and building up a
engagement in technical subjects and the
preparation they need to get degrees in
this area is important and also as has
been mentioned and will be mentioned
many times today the immigration
policies we have which create various
barriers not insurmountable but still
barriers for the many students who come
here study in our universities and
actually would like to stay in this
country because they see it as the place
to be innovators that we need to keep
that open and make those possibilities
available then the final thing I'll say
is to compare you can't really compare
Infosys to Microsoft even though they
sound very similar the reality is
Infosys is a company where the people
come in and they're mostly coming out of
the mid-level colleges of India the
so-called regional engineering colleges
they are not coming from the India
institutes of technology which is a
miniscule fraction of the total output
of the university system in India and so
they're coming in rather poorly trained
in fact and that's why they have to go
through an 18-month training at infosys
before they can become productive and
even then the kind of work they do is
much more lower on the food chain so to
speak of IT innovation so the u.s. still
has a huge edge in being the place where
the most innovative products come out in
the computer industry and not just
Microsoft but look to companies like
Google and Facebook as well as being
companies that are driving whole new
economies and whole new types of
products whole new business models
through innovation in computers and
computing IT
Thank You Randy Thank You panel now at
this point we'd like to turn a little
over to you all if you have any
questions raise your hand if I catch you
I your if you catch my eye you you will
be the next batter I see one behind the
podium hey good morning since I I work
for a software company who'd like to to
add something here to what the panel has
said very briefly to your point about
about the future no we don't know what
type of application this industry is
going to to provide we just don't know
but a lot of things are going to happen
social networking for once which is now
limited to the Facebook you know that we
hope use Facebook of this world lots of
applications for government security
health care customer relations obviously
this is one of the issues and domains
where other thing I going to happen
about the new technology development
model yes the u.s. still retain a huge
edge very true but look at the most
successful iPhone applications that was
developed in ghana by a guy called Henry
who even in an avin iphone he used the
iphone demo on the internet to develop
one of these applications and he sent it
to to apple and a and it send Henry a
very fat check back so this is the new
bubble where innovation in the software
industry happens everywhere every time
places like Jordan Egypt Dubai guitar
are starting to also have their own
center of excellence therefore software
so what I'm saying that yes the u.s.
still written an edge Europe is far
behind but we must be very careful
because mother has changed the system
has the ecosystem is changing so we need
to put our together and I think I open
on education later today we'll talk
about a little bit I think the question
is to comment on the comment it's a
really good point that things like the
iphone has enabled very small
individuals really to have a product get
it into a parka
and get sales going on it that otherwise
would have taken all the forces of a
large company to make things happen and
as a result it respects no national
boundaries that it wherever a smart and
creative and entrepreneurial person is
doesn't need lots of resources doesn't
need a big loan from the bank to make it
happen and it really is remarkable and I
think my view by the way is I i really
think that the global I tia is a
something where many boats get raised by
the growing industry and I'm glad to see
innovation happening outside of the US
as well yeah well head Bill fire chief
just cut this actually your comment
really is very often though because it
actually cuts both ways on the one hand
the growing sophistication up for
technology and the stack has drastically
lowered the barriers to entry somebody
can gone up creating a successful iphone
app no one but on the other hand app
still firmly Steve heck yeah i wanted to
say i think the indian software industry
is a kind of parable for something a lot
broader in terms of globalization which
is when you look at the indian software
industry a lot of it not not my aim is
all of it was fueled by people who are
trained in the united states who cut
their teeth in organizations again
particularly in Silicon Valley many of
whom at one point started firms in the
US but then were pivotal in connecting
Indian software firms are getting them
going with us firms and in in the long
run I think Randy's right I served on a
national academy of sciences panel on
the ITR d ecosystem the surprising thing
is not only does not seem to have cut
into US jobs it seems to have almost
stimulated the industry in the United
States so so why would that be true why
would there be this virtual beneficial
cycle well the answer is as time goes on
it's the whole idea of trade
specialization you get if India tis not
specializing in packaged software which
is much more what you see in the United
States it's enabling the US firms to
specialize more what they're good at at
the same time is creating these
opportunities for India but if you can't
keep getting the goose laying the golden
eggs if you don't in the United States
support the emerging specialization in
this more basic side of the industry so
the panel that I was on look carefully
if for instance DARPA which you know
advanced part of the defense industry
used to spend a lot of money supporting
both education and R&D in the software
industry not only is it declined but
there really hasn't been a substitute
for it in the United States so you have
to have everything working in
coordination and so I think there's
still opportunities but in all the
developed countries that they've got to
be aware of what it takes in terms of
commitments to R&D in education and I
think that's something in the prior ten
years we saw really decline in the
United States hopefully we're seeing
signs now under the current
administration of changing I think this
is a place where the Europeans have been
much more ahead of us and it's it's
something that really has to go hand in
hand with the kind of globalization
taking advantage of these trends not
resisting them and I think you've
introduced Martians comment go ahead
thank you I'm actually very worried
about the big fat check to Henry in
Ghana and as me let me explain why
because it's a spread camp in his speech
at the beginning said this discussion
today is not only what's good for the US
but also what's good for the global
economy g20 and I wish that Henry
instead of getting the check from Apple
for selling his ideas would rather stay
in Ghana and develop his idea in Ghana
so that it will be a Henry incorporated
company soon to be listed either on
asiago ideally in Accra stock exchange
because they would be a way for
diversifying the fruits of global
economic growth I think there's one of
the problems which I also wanted to talk
about in the second
part of my speech which is what needs to
be done to make sure that all countries
in a global economy can take party and
innovation and can benefit from
innovation and I think here there's
there's a lot of things that that would
need to be done there's also an example
of Israel with one of the most
successful stories of building up IT
industry from almost scratch and with
all these Israeli companies being listed
on NASDAQ and New York Stock Exchange's
than elsewhere the problem is though
when if you look at the Israeli economy
there's very little linkage between the
very successful ICT industry in Israel
and the rest of the economy this
virtually no spill overs the Israeli
innovators get all the money or the
billions they cooperate with US
companies they develop new things but it
has very little influence on non ite
industries in Israel and as a result
Israel as a whole is growing slower than
it could have been so the big question
to all of us and I think to the g20
summit is what do you do for the Henry
in Ghana to actually stay home and
develop his company there and probably
sell products to American consumers and
polish consumers Thank You Erica I know
that's right down the pike of your
studies uh so I think what's nice about
your example is that it also points out
specific characteristics of software and
of the platform enabled by Apple that
let that happen that let Henry develop
his technology on the Apple platform
from far away and I think it's important
to then say in what industries in what
cases is that possible and what cases is
that not possible today and so the
example that comes to mind for me is the
photonics industry today Oh or which is
a semiconductor industry which is about
where electronic semiconductors would
have been 30 years ago so we care about
photonics because they matter for
telecom and communications for sensors
for medical applications for solar
applications
in the long term and today in photonics
on the manufacturing shop floor they
have yields of 2.3 three-point-nine
percent so two-point-three percent of
what goes in the door actually makes it
out the back end and they're highly
skilled PhDs are actually on the
manufacturing line playing around it's a
craft based industry they don't know how
to get these products out the door and
they can't just take these guys off the
manufacturing line without manufacturing
line stopping pushing products out all
together and so here's a high-tech
industry a chemical based industry a
process based industry where it's not
possible for someone far away to invent
on the manufacturing process line and
the question starts to become where can
you do that and what industries like
software is that enabled and where is
that not possible and what does that
mean for we're going to locate
activities server you want to wrap this
up and we're going to look for another
question yes I just wanted to say that
this whole story about the Indian
software industry actually not hurting
but helping the u.s. software industry
developed further is just an example
well the most recent example of things
that economists have known for ages like
when the industrial revolution happened
in Britain the ludus wanted to destroy
the machines that were supposedly
replacing workers and leading to the
loss of jobs when industrial industrial
style agriculture commercial agriculture
started emerging in England for the
first time there were enclosures and
peasants were driven from lands to make
room for sheep and a lot of economists
at the time including notably Karl Marx
wrote about sheep eating people somehow
all these gloomy predictions that the
developments that displaces workers
would would really approve completely
their standards of living have failed to
materialize if there is anything new in
this software now I'm not a software
specialist but from what I hear there is
anything new about this current stage is
that the potential for growth are even
more immense because you can take this
iphone application and you can
instantaneously they reach literally
hundreds of millions of consumers
worldwide which was something that was
not possible without
this kind of technology in the 18th or
19th century so the responsibility is
very strongly on the side of countries
like the US where at the technological
age to keep pushing it forward and that
could lead to much faster actual growth
in the future than we have experienced
in the past thank you yes just hear my
name is Caroline Kaufman I'm a lifetime
resident of Pittsburgh and have lived
through many of the economic downturns
and upturns that our region is
experienced I was particularly intrigued
by erikas comments about manufacturing
because while I have a son who's an IT
genius I also have other members of my
family who are very good with their
hands who would like to be machinists
and intrigued by the possibility that we
have an educated workforce that are
educated in other aspects of the
manufacturing process and who actually
like to build things with their hands
I'm also a fan of Paul free look Goodman
and his point about how we are
developing the ideas and then off citing
the actual manufacturing and then and
then importing these things back is a
strange cycle because we could be
building the wind turbines here we could
be building the silicon sheets for
photovoltaic cells here particularly in
an area like western Pennsylvania which
has a a large a long-standing tradition
of a manufacturing base and I'm
wondering if the panel could comment
upon that if you will hands-on aspect of
the labor force given the fact that CMU
produces remarkably and genius-level IT
specialists but then the region actually
builds its middle class growth on people
who make things with their hands that
should take us for the rest of such go
ahead
I want to make one sort of expanding
coming in one clarifying comment I don't
fall kind of in the same boat as most
economists in the sense that what's
different about the argument that I
generally make is that when you move
manufacturing you change the most
competitive technologies and thereby the
trajectory of the firm and the industry
as it changes manufacturing locations
due to differences in different
manufacturing locations so that it's a
bit of a different argument and it has
different implications for what you
might want to do about that you might
want to understand what our consumer
preferences and what our manufacturing
differences in China and how will that
change the economic viability of energy
savings technologies for automobiles in
the future as demand in China for
automobiles supersedes demand for China
for automobiles for example in the
United States but that being said I have
in one of the two industries that I
really have focused on there is a case
where on the ground understanding of the
technology and of the manufacturing
process is key in that industry for
being able to get products out the door
in the new technology back in the United
States and they did not at this stage
have that type of expertise in China and
you can actually it's an industry the
photonics industry the people who have
this particular expertise it's so small
you can count the professors and the
graduate students they've been producing
and how many of those graduate students
theres two now one who's a professor at
the University of Hong Kong and China
one who's gone over to Singapore so you
can trace these people and how that
knowledge might be starting to flow
overseas and those capabilities but the
problem is that we don't yet in this
industry have CAD technologies or
software technologies that enable people
to do the designs here in the United
States and move the manufacturing
overseas and so what that would suggest
is that if we do want to produce these
new technologies and we do believe
that's important then there that
Manufacturing may indeed have to stay
here in its early stages when it's a
high-tech brand new firm it's small it
doesn't have yet a large market and that
they're there really is a demand for the
manufacturing still here in the United
States which it's a very new it's a very
nuanced sort of sector where that
becomes a real problem and I know I know
Steve wants to jump in on this one okay
guy i I really don't think that the
future is bright for the hands-on
manufacturing side in Pittsburgh and I
don't think it's bright for anywhere in
the United States but that's not a bad
thing I think if you look at a lot of
the sources of growth in Pittsburgh I've
been here 30 years you look at health
care you look at sort of semiconductor
IT you look even at banking these are
really service-based areas and they're
exploiting the fact that the
manufacturing side can be done cheaper
in countries like Taiwan which has
developed a really vibrant semiconductor
production fabrication business which
has enabled the united states that
specialize in the design of
semiconductors that's the kind of thing
that CMU is perfectly well suited to
train people and has trained an enormous
amount of people it's very much a kind
of IT based business we I think now have
about twelve percent of our labor force
in manufacturing that's really an
extraordinarily low number but if you
look back 20 or 30 years ago these same
themes came up I remember the cover of
Time magazine featured the idea of the
hallowed corporation in the united
states decrying the fact that we were
manufacturing less and less and was
going to jeopardize the future of
economic growth in the US and you'll
dial forward 20 years i think that's
been completely wrong the growth in the
United States has been driven
particularly by IT that's where a lot of
the productivity events has come so it's
hard to see resisting that in the future
it seems to me a better strategy as
embracing it and figuring out what you
do is a region to write it
I would love to get a question from one
of our students they're trying to hide I
can tell we're walking a mic back to the
student the student is not figuring out
your question I wanted to ask one of the
comments that has one of those topics
has been kind of brought up multiple
times is the role of technology and data
and its role in innovation and one of
ways we want to ask is one of the terms
that's been thrown around especially
within the IT industry is it the last
year and a half two years or so has been
the concept of cloud computing storage
of data in the cloud the movement of
software to the cloud and while that had
and that has some relatively easy asius
and benefits and some risks for both in
terms of the accessibility of resources
and the flexibility well it has the
dangers of data security and downtime my
question was kind of focused on how does
that impact innovation especially the
startup of new firms and their ability
to access those resources that sounds
like Randy's question actually the
ability of cloud computing which
actually that term has become such a
buzz word that means different things to
many different people but let's use the
definition here of that the IT
infrastructure is not necessarily owned
by the company that's making use of it
but rather by a service company that's
providing it a great example is Amazon
we know as a online shopping place but
they're making a serious business out of
providing both computer cycles and the
storage capability to many companies and
it's also similar to what we're talking
about with the iPhone become this
amazing way that people with relatively
small amounts of capitalization can jump
into an IT enabled business so a lot of
the in fact essentially all of the
recent startup companies of so-called
web 20 companies are making use of cloud
computing
their basis because it means that rather
than having to take your precious
venture capital essentially diluting the
equity in your company by buying a
depreciated asset depreciating asset
namely computers you can sort of rent it
from these companies as and as your
revenue grows you just rent more
capacity a few revenue shrinks you rent
less and so you're not is beholden to
very difficult planning and procurement
cycles as well so it's also become one
of these great things that takes makes
it possible for small individuals with
very minimal capitalization to jump into
business and become entrepreneurs I'm
going to do something here now we have
about six minutes left and I'm going to
challenge our panel to give us 45
seconds to 1 minute summaries of what
they've seen from here or some poetic
beauty they want to impart to us at this
point now I'm looking for a volunteer to
go first because I did not warn them
about this particular activity seeing no
volunteers I volunteer a volunteer thank
you I'm sorry to say but I must
disappoint Pittsburgh and I must
disappoint America because I think we
should be from an objective global point
of view we should be discussing more
about how you create jobs outside of
America and outside of Pittsburgh then
creating jobs here if you wanna spread
wealth if you want to make sure that the
global economy is growing for everyone
and that everyone takes part in growth
including billions of people in Africa
in Asia that have unbelievably lower
standards of living than we are we all
here and i think the discussion should
be how do we help Henry in Ghana to set
up his business how do we help Indian
Infosys and others to make sure that
they not only islands of prosperity and
new technology that the Slumdog
Millionaire
movie will only very soon become history
and there will be no slums in India and
that all the other guys that were
depicting in the movie can actually
benefit from innovation because again
from a global point of view the question
is how do you spread jobs and how do you
spread innovation from the US and
developed countries to others so that
they can also benefit to thank you Bill
you want to comment on bollywood or you
have your own comment actually I think
that an area of growing engagement and
excitement in our community of computer
scientists is what we call ICT for
development this has been an area of
focus certainly here at carnegie mellon
at other universities including berkeley
for more than a decade most recently for
example Bill Gates came to the Carnegie
Mellon campus in Doha Qatar to talk
about this topic the developing world
what's the role of ICT it's not about
air-dropping hundred-dollar laptops into
remote rural villages in India or Africa
it's a much more subtle and nuanced
story and it talks it addresses issues
related to success in agriculture to
success in e-government or a number of
topics so I think that that in fact many
people in ICT see this as an opportunity
to 2 raise to raise the level for the
bottom third Sergei yeah I want to say
basically well in the similar vein the
continued the topics that we already
talked about here the importance for
particular for developing countries so
by Diaz an opportunity is something that
cannot be exaggerated and I just don't
know how many people like Henry before
the advent of the internet and iPhone
used to live their whole lives in
cool locations and never you know get
anything to do with their talent and
never get noticed by anyone at all so
there are a lot of things to be done to
foster development but the provision of
ideas and opportunities and of
information is I think something that
can be done given the global stage the
current state of Technology very easily
and without you know thinking of how to
introduce more sound government or
develop financial markets or other
things that are that are immensely more
difficult so one thing that I think the
which is the responsibility of the
United States and other advanced nations
did you rethink the role of intellectual
property rights and all this for
instance as again this I've heard this
debate for a couple of years away the
Google wants to scan all the books in
basically all the libraries and make
them freely available on the internet
they want to do it as a business and
somehow their vested interests that keep
resisting this and if anything did then
the trend in the u.s. in particular in
the past few decays has been to
strengthen rather than loosen
intellectual property rights which
really goes against all these or obese
friends particularly harmful to to the
spread of knowledge and ideas to
developing right so i think the policy
that the US has with regard intellectual
property has to be reconsidered
including the non-compete agreements
that Steven mentions are not limited to
that in a lot of aspects whenever we can
provide free information whenever
this is like Google who want to take
this up as absolutely no reason to
restrain them see we have a two-minute
warning three professors for two minutes
what we talked a lot about the u.s.
spurring innovation and benefiting the
world I want to talk about one gigantic
challenge that's moving for that role
that's dealing with energy and dealing
with climate control obviously were laid
back when oil prices skyrocketed in the
1970s us productivity growth slowed down
enormously took a big hit for a long
time we still haven't we still don't
have an energy policy in the United
States and a failure I think it's just
that a year to away we're going to be
back up at high oil prices and it looks
like something to stick given the growth
that's occurred in India and China
that's spurring a lot of this so if the
United States is going to play this
continue to play this role and provide
benefits throughout the world due to it
pursuing its own self-interest going to
have to figure out what to do about
energy policy Thank You Erica sure I
want to make one short comment to
Carolyn's question which is just with
less than twenty eight percent of
manufacturing value-added currently in
the u.s. that number has continued to
decline I do think there's a fascinating
question with respect to military
procurement and what's going to happen
with respect to where the military is
going to get its manufacturing
technologies and that's a question for
another time but in terms of concluding
remarks I think there's often this
problem of the u.s. is worried about
what's going to china china is worried
about copying the united states and one
of the things that we forget in that
debate is that there are these national
differences and that what is the most
economically viable technology United
States is not necessarily the most
economically viable technology both from
a manufacturing and from a consumer
preferred standpoint in China or in
other countries and so the question is
how can we leverage those national
differences how can countries not just
try to copy each other but leverage that
to the greater greater in obey
globally and greater advancement of our
society thank you right so I'm going to
jump into topic for which I have no
qualifications to talk about but in ants
the issue raised about can we really
afford to lose all the jobs that involve
hands-on work I think it's a really
fundamental core issue for our country
of what is the meaning of I think the
students coming out of Carnegie Mellon
are going to do great in this world
they'll be very competing an
international scope at the highest
levels but what does it mean for the
half or more of our country who are
looking for what you'd call more
vocational jobs that traditionally you
could be trained through apprenticeship
or through a vocational votec college
for a job that would last you your
lifetime using roughly the same skills
over and over again and now we're in a
world where these basic job skills turn
over every five to ten years so the only
hope is to make people be able to learn
and learn and relearn over time and I
don't think we've developed the
educational system that's capable of
that I don't think we've developed the
expectations among what's called in blue
collar workers that they will have to
continually renew their skills and
perhaps move completely from say being a
factory worker to being part of the
service economy and I think it's a very
core question for this country that's a
difficult one thank you well perhaps by
that comment you've seen that
Schumpeter's directive of creative
destruction is always a challenge and
never really has a perfect answer what
we hope to do today is to shed some
light on the subjects and give you a
mosaic of innovation and how it could
come and the challenges it has been an
honor to serve with this great panel and
it's been an honor to have you as our
audience and we thank you very very much
for attending
you